airline voll mit fernweh und heimweh
werden präsentiert von swiss ein
gästehaus auf der insel bali patricia
und romano tschudi wollen aus dem alltag
ausbrechen familie folgt sie sucht ihr
glück in kanada in den rocky mountains
bauen sie ein holzfäller unternehmen auf
tobias bayer und michael paris wollen
eigentlich etwas eigenes eine kleine bar
auf weite ventura
[Musik]
am rand von u boot einem touristenort im
landesinneren der insel bali liegt das
gästehaus von auswanderer romano tschudi
wo zwei tagen erst hatte es übernommen
jetzt muss er hier der chef sein
romano möchte das haus mit drei zimmern
zu einem bed and breakfast umbauen
hilfe bekommt er von hausmeister cat den
er vom vermieter übernommen hat
eigentlich startet in der letzten folge
abschied von ehefrau patricia die wegen
ihren job zurück bleiben musste
romano reist er alleine voraus vermieter
frank übergaben ihm auf bali das
gästehaus und damit viel arbeit
[Musik]
tobias und michael fuhren mit dem auto
nach fuerteventura nur 30000 franken
haben sie für ihr neues leben und der
ausbau ihrer bar ist bereits einen monat
im verzug
der test bestanden die neue holzernte
maschine der familie volk ist bereit für
kanada dann der schock
sie bekommen kein visum
gott ist alles irgendwie toll
[Musik]
es gibt kein zurück für familie volk sie
hat ihre zelte in der schweiz
abgebrochen ihr forstunternehmen
verkauft und die geschäftsleitung
abgegeben aber ohne visum können sie
nicht nach kanada
selbst ihr wohnhaus übergeben sie in
wenigen tagen an den neuen besitzer
irgendwie warum sie kein visum bekommen
hatten die behörden nicht begründet
jetzt müssen sie umplanen ehemann
christian und mitarbeiter mehr konnte er
auch mit nach kanada kommt suchen einen
späteren termin für den export ihrer
holzernte maschinen
[Musik]
auf bali trifft hausmeister cat beim
gästehaus ein zwei stunden zu spät
morgen hast du verschlafen
bei mir das geregnet um 19 uhr
wir haben jetzt elf uhr am samstag komme
ich nicht zu arbeiten
warum nicht ich muss zu hause an meine
arbeit und ich kann keine handwerker
bezahlen
ich werde die arbeit nächste woche
nachholen nächste bekommst du also drei
tage so sicher denn wir haben viel
arbeit
romano arbeitete in der schweiz als lkw
disponent auf bali ist ein
selbstständiger unternehmer der sagen
muss was langgeht
speziell plötzlich mussawi sich jetzt
gar und so da bin immer nur diese szene
wird oder wenn das man einfach heute ein
sprachlich dass man ganz klar habe ich
sie gar und der weiß was läuft und ob
ich mal garnicht sich andere für sich
arbeiten lassen ist für romano noch
fremd
[Musik]
noch ist zwischen saison in corralejo
doch in wenigen wochen werden die gassen
der altstadt voller touristen seien
[Musik]
tobias bayer und michael paris gehen die
baupläne ihre bar durch die architektin
hat zwar die pläne geliefert aber mehr
ist bisher nicht passiert
ihnen bleiben nur noch vier wochen
unbedingt das ruft die schlacht die
beiden haben ein knappes budget und nur
wenig spielraum im einkaufszentrum l
campana rio weg vom meer und ein wenig
abseits von zentrum liegt ihre
zukünftige bar
kontakt
mit konzerten und anderen
veranstaltungen möchte die leitung des
einkaufszentrums feriengäste anlocken
die beiden sind zu einem ortstermin mit
der architektin verabredet
hoffen sie jetzt nichts mehr in der
mitte die zuschauer los
[Musik]
tobias und michael sind pünktlich vor
ort im gegensatz zur spanischen
architekten
[Musik]
im zürcher weinland haben die volks
inzwischen neue instruktionen von ihrem
auswanderungs berater erhalten
ganz neu sie füllen den antrag für ihr
visum nun von hand aus den letzten haben
sie online eingereicht ja weil wir
dürfen nicht auswandern weil sie es uns
abgelehnt haben
und jetzt mal alles nochmal in
papierform schlägt gewählt dieses fand
rechtsberatung meinte dass sie die
möglichkeit dass es dann halt vielleicht
licht akzeptiert wird ja doch macht er
stellte dann unverhofft eine mail vom
auswanderungs berater online status of
publication has changed refused ist
replaced by so bietet luxus nicht das
letzte mal war ja geschlossen und
reviews und jetzt ist wieder deuce
dinge und dass sie einfach in
bearbeitung ist er seither kurve ruhiges
wochenende
also irgendwie hängt doch wo ist
wahnsinn
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
erhalten falls ihr visum doch noch mit
dem ersten antrag
auf bali muss der bambus weg ein arzt
droht das dach des hauses zu beschädigen
chef roman packt mit an
[Musik]
danke für deine hilfe zusammen
im gästehaus haben bisher
rucksacktouristen mit kleinem
portemonnaie übernachtet zukünftig
möchte romano mehr geld verlangen der
grund komplett verrußt dass damit sich
gäste hier wohlfühlen muss er die zimmer
renovieren und neu ausstatten
in drei monaten waren schuldig eröffnen
mit mir ist die verdienen ob ich sage
ganz klar wie vor jemanden nach und umso
besser
[Musik]
kesswil im kanton thurgau
hier haben romano und seine frau
patricia in den letzten neun jahren
gewohnt bis das geschäft in bali läuft
boden stieß das haus untervermieten
nur noch wenige wochen dann verlässt
auch patricia ihre gewohnte umgebung
aufs nacht es die schalt märkte vor
antritt steht dass mir das merkt man
halt schon bis jetzt arbeitet die 56
jährige als bereichsleiterin bei einem
deutschen grossverteiler in der schweiz
für ihre auswanderung gibt sie die feste
anstellung mit regelmäßigem gehalt auf
doch das dass sie immer alles mit
sicherheit macht planer können wir
natürlich mit dem projekt eines wie viel
und du musst sie einfach mal lehre dass
nicht alles planbar ist und was man
group langhammer gemacht und rushes ja
warum ich zu tun das ist so
es ist um
liebgewonnene gegenstände die sie nicht
nach bali mitnehmen kann
verwahrt patricia vorerst sicher auf dem
dachboden
keine spur von der architektin auf worte
ventura
[Musik]
doch dann
architektin rugby ist da 30 minuten zu
spät
[Musik]
gehen wir auf die andere seite
haben sie einen schlüssel für das lokal
haben sie noch keinen schlüssel
denken sie dass wir nächste woche mit
dem ausbau beginnen können
ja klar ich sagte allem dass sie am
montag bereit sein müssen um mit der
arbeit zu beginnen
[Musik]
auf 50 quadratmetern wollen sie ihren
gemeinsamen traum verwirklichen eine bar
mit souvenir shop
[Musik]
naja sind noch unsicher wegen des
souvenirshops dieser bereich ist 3 auf 3
meter groß aber wir können ihn auch
größer machen drei metern für die es
wäre gut sieben meter für die bank zu
haben
ich möchte das gern mal ab stars hätte
ventura der name der bar steht schon
lange fest
und auch die einrichtung haben die
beiden schon genau vor augen mit trecker
aus große t shirts probieren sagt sie
ist eigentlich schon alles spaß machen
und hat nicht gut sagen eigentlich die
artikel mit diesem norbert hofer
verkaufen und 2 2 nach einer bar
die auswanderer denken bereits in großen
dimensionen noch bevor sie ihren ersten
cocktail verkauft haben
[Musik]
jestetten gleich hinter der schweizer
grenze familie volk ist bei simones
eltern untergekommen
ihr haus wussten sie bereits an den
neuen besitzer übergeben
seitdem leben sie aus dem koffer doch
john und simone sind bester laune
irgendwer wir heute eine party
wir können es irgendwie noch gar nicht
richtig glauben will mir handys ich
bitte mir gerechnet dass das jetzt doch
noch auf der trage klappt also wirklich
nicht überhaupt nicht warum die
kanadischen behörden ihren
ursprünglichen antrag nun doch noch
bewilligt haben bleibt unklar
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die anspannung der letzten tage aus
warten hoffen und bangen hat nun ein
ende
[Musik]
für familie volk ist der weg nach kanada
endlich frei sohn john wird seinen
cousins und cousinen bald für lange zeit
gut bei sein müssen
[Musik]
romano hat sich für einen ganzen tag
einen schub für bestellt
er möchte in die hauptstadt der insel
nach dem paradies brauchen neue möbel
pierre gästehaus dort die verschiedenen
ob große bürger woschitz was hochstifts
preisvergleich dass ich zehn modellen
stoppte das sagen so der planung verfügt
dafür hat sich romano im internet
verschiedene adressen von möbelhäusern
heraus geschrieben
die kleine straße ist es
die erste adresse befindet sich in einem
wohngebiet eine schule eine moschee
sonst nichts
wir sind am richtigen august prägen wir
die türkei laufen oder wir finden nicht
in frage
das ist denn auch das findet sie
die anwohnerin kann auch nicht
weiterhelfen
[Musik]
ich gebe dir die nächste adresse
versuch nummer zwei
[Musik]
wir werden dieses gerät anders
immer schön dass hier wo es liegt wie
volltreffer internet ein möbelhaus am
anderen ende der welt zu finden ist
schwerer als gedacht auf fuerteventura
hat die architektin endlich die
kostenvoranschläge geliefert tobias und
michael müssen entscheiden wie sie ihre
bar ausstatten wollen luxuriös oder
einfach ihr budget 30000 franken mehr
haben sie nicht eingeplant sind außer
frage
ich sehe wie hart ich ist das auch die
luft mit architektin der weltweite
nummer unter der woche für das bedürfnis
termine und themen erstellt vielleicht
bei den islam 2000 euro aber ab solange
aber es ist heute tue sich stürzen am
ende gekostet aber wir schon davor
schützen glaubt es hätte so an das
trauma also wir brauchen schon qualität
und darum das muss man schon etwas
investieren
durch das sort zu mit deiner papier
vorstellen
[Musik]
bis der umbau beginnt genießen tobias
und michael die schönen zeiten forte
ventouras an ihrem lieblingsplatz
denn klicken bei eliot elia
du musst dich mal stücke noch mal ja
sie hoffen dass wir glück haben ist ein
bisschen warten
willkommen war die erste münchner
[Musik]
gestalteten festwagen
was er macht von
tobias und michael sind seit zwölf
jahren ein paar
die gemeinsame bringt sie noch näher
zusammen und wochenende unterschieden
college und klar ist aber dass habe
gegen eine zusatzbatterie
[Musik]
das glück könnte perfekt werden wenn
sich die beiden nicht mit der bafa
kalkulieren
[Musik]
auswanderer christian volk auf
besonderer mission mit 20 kilometern pro
stunde geht es richtung grenze
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die speziell ausgerüsteten holzernte
maschinen gehen heute auf die lange
reise nach kanada
[Musik]
egal wie
von hier an müssen christian und mirko
die maschinen anderen anvertrauen
einfach alles klappt also dass jetzt
auch klappen aber das klappt die
maschinen werden im belgischen zeebrügge
nach kanada verschifft hafenarbeiter
werden dort die kostbare fracht aufs
schiff fahren müssen
christian beschriftet die steuerung er
hofft dass die belgier damit klarkommen
und seine babys gut behandeln die
maschine sind der aufbau der basis eines
indischen
die erste etappe leben die maschinen auf
den tieflader zurück
[Musik]
hallo lange währt wird endlich gut zu
werden
[Musik]
mit fernfahrer klaus arbeitet christian
schon lange zusammen
er bringt die wertvolle fracht bis zum
überseehafen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
120.000
volks gesamtes hab und gut ist unterwegs
nach kanada sie stehen jetzt fast mit
leeren händen da
[Musik]
auf bali sucht auswanderer romano die
noch immer noch möbelhäusern die
adressen der aus dem internet heraus
geschrieben hatte stimmen so nicht
er fragt sich durch entschuldigung
kennen sie war die deko ja ungefähr
einen kilometer von hier einen kilometer
gibt es da mehrere läden und tatsächlich
einen kilometer weiter endlich das
gesuchte möbelgeschäft ich geh doch mal
rein
romano braucht neue möbel für alle drei
gästezimmer
kann ich ihnen helfen ich schaue mich
gerne erstmal später com ist dann mit
vielen fragen romano hat so seine
vorstellungen welche möbel passen würden
pelzig weil du ihm einfach aus unterseen
und da finde ich jetzt bin ich mir ganz
witzig daher seine strom sich auf seine
alten fischerboot macht
die möbel gefallen romano haben aber
auch ihren preis
er wird deshalb noch weitere läden
aufsuchen
ich mache zwar immer wieder mal fotos
von sache wohl nicht mehr ins auge
springen
und die wird die den halter patricia den
mittlerweile einfach so dass man den
schlussendlich halt doch bis zur suche
das ist nur wichtig dass sie nicht
kontrolle sei entscheid die zimmer
einzurichten feld römer nur leicht aber
wieso dies überhaupt gäste zum eher
abgelegenen bed and breakfast locken
wollen
darüber haben sie sich bisher kaum
gedanken gemacht
[Musik]
michael um tobias wollen geld sparen und
so schnell wie möglich raus aus ihrem
teuren ferienappartement sie klappern
verschiedene maklerbüros ab auf der
suche nach einer günstigen und schönen
wohnung
ich bin tobias schön sie kennenzulernen
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
wir suchen was zur langzeitmiete wir
wissen der wohnungsmarkt ist
ausgetrocknet im moment vielleicht kann
sie trotzdem was für die viele person
nur wir zwei und ihre frauen dass sie zu
hause
nein keine frauen im moment ist das
angebot sehr klein aber wir hätten
vielleicht ein zwei wohnungen wäre es
möglich diese anzuschauen
danke vielmals schön sie getroffen zu
haben konnten sie der sohn von makler
jan-olaf nimmt sie mit zum appartement
es liegt gleich um die ecke im wenig
gepflegten zentrum von corralejo zehn
autominuten von ihrer bar entfernt
[Musik]
650 euro kostet die zweizimmerwohnung
vom balkon der ring back home ja sagen
die besichtigung fällt kurz aus excel
oder access einfach nicht ist das also
da würde ich auf keinen fall wohnen also
ich dass er lieber ich schlafe mein
laden dann ich weiß nicht so lange es
nötig ist aber dass ich würde auf keinen
fall metern
[Musik]
in zürich geht es für familie volk
endlich los der flieger nach kanada hebt
ihn zwei stunden ab im schlepptau
familienangehörige und freunde zum
check-in kommt mitarbeiter mirco als
letzter auch er wandert nun aus
schon heute abend beginnt für familie
volk das neue leben ja aber letztlich
alle kräfte langsam wenn wir da züge zu
recht hat richtig flügel konnte das neue
womit man hofft ja sobald auch wenn
dabei die letzten minuten auf schweizer
boden
john und mutter simone müssen nun ihre
liebsten zurücklassen
[Musik]
recke
so haben zufrieden war
wir fördern
dirk wendelmuth nicht mehr gab es gar
nicht
[Musik]
als erwartet
jetzt darf dank
[Musik]
auch patricia muss abschied nehmen
sie hat heute ihren letzten arbeitstag
seit 2007 ist sie bereichsleiterin zoll
bei einem deutschen grossverteiler in
der schweiz
nach der halbjahres kompakter stehen und
abteilungschef dem haarspitzen
am hauptsitz in weinfelden ist patricia
für sämtliche zeuge lange zuständig ein
shop mit viel verantwortung gutem gehalt
und geschäftszahlen
hallo alles gut
patricia führt ein team von acht
mitarbeitern bald wechselt sie vom büro
im industriequartier ins bett and
breakfast unter palmen funktionieren
[Musik]
kreativ auf bali schafft ihr mann romano
platz für die neuen möbel vermieter
frank bürger soll die alten sachen aus
den zimmern abholen
[Musik]
eine gelegenheit für romano ihm einige
mängel am gästehaus zu zeigen
[Musik]
ja da muss man das macht ja danke dass
ich das mal über können und sorge was
rohstoffe mit aus selbst die reparatur
muss romano bezahlen obwohl er das haus
nur gemietet hat stattliche 750 franken
bekommt vermieter frank pro monat
[Musik]
und da waren wir nicht ganz verstanden
also nicht dass er sehr hoch ist da
waren sie sich was mir jetzt mit drin
stecken
das sicher neu verhandeln
[Musik]
in weinfelden hat patricia ihren
schreibtisch geräumt geschäfts telefon
und batch abgegeben
jetzt bleibt nur noch der abschieds
apero das abschiedsgeschenk geld für ein
rückflugticket zwei raclette öfen und
ein gedicht oder und patricia über acht
jahre schmeißt du den laden und einen
rucksack mit erfahrung von belohnt doch
diese zeit ist nun vorbei
danke für morgen
das alte leben loslassen fällt patricia
schwer
[Musik]
familie volk ist zwar in kanada
angekommen aber noch nicht ganz am ziel
in der größten stadt der region
organisieren sie seit drei tagen alles
für einen guten start
sie haben zwei geländewagen gekauft und
für den wald ausgerichtet das frühstück
passt auch schon stellt kartoffeln und
eier
heute beziehen volks ihr neues daheim
allerdings das haus liegt im dorf
clearwater rund 500 kilometer entfernt
ich liebe
als ziele zwei heimischen zehn jahren
drauf drauf mit den neuen pick ups geht
es richtung clearwater in sieben stunden
ist dort schlüsselübergabe nächste woche
die 500 kilometer durch kanada werden
zur nervenprobe und im neuen zuhause
muss familie volk improvisieren
auf bali kommen patricia und romano
wieder zusammen
nach sieben wochen patricia inspiziert
das renovierte gästehaus erste zweifel
tauchen auf fuerteventura brauchen
tobias und michael dringend eine wohnung
das social geschenk bank und der ausbau
ihrer bar geht nur schleppend voran
[Musik]
sid
airline fernsehen präsentiert wurde